traduction avant cela revenons si vous
voulez si vous le voulez bien sur
l'événement de cette journée un mur qui
s'effondre 28 ans ce mur a donc été
érigé pour couper une ville pour couper
un pays et aussi pour couper deux
Europes c'était le 13 août 1961 en
pleine guerre froide les autorités est
allemandes l'avaient édifié en une nuit
ce mur est devenu un symbole depuis un
symbole qui est tombé aujourd'hui
Philippe couder juin 88 concert de rock
à Berlin Ouest de l'autre côté la police
charge les jeune car il s'approche trop
près du mur pour écouter Michael Jackson
juin 89 dernier anniversaire du mur de
la honte la contestation éclate de part
et d'autres de Checkpoint Charlie pour
les manifestants ce mur long de 111 km
doit tomber ce soir c'est choses faites
pour passer de l'autre côté il ne faudra
plus sauter les barbelés comme ce soldat
est allemand ou ruser comme ce chauffeur
de taxi lui il a fait le mur en
compagnie de deux mannequins déguisés en
militaire
soviétique en revanche 77 transfuge
auront été depuis 1961 abatus par les
vaupau des centaines de familles
divisées des destins séparés des vies
brisées Berlin un cancer au cœur de
l'Europe avec son mur ses secteurs ses
crises successives l'Europe qui
s'installe dans la guerre froide le
face- à- faceace permanent entre les
forces alliées et les troupes
soviétiques à l'instar de John fitzerold
Kennedy l'ensemble du monde occidental
devient berlinois il faudra attendre
1970 pour qu'interviennent les premiers
signes de détente le Premier ministre
est emand et Monsieur stof le chancelier
fénéral se nomme Brant en commun ils ont
au moins un prénom vly ils vont
inaugurer une phase de cohabitation
voire de détente mais les candidats au
passage à l'ouest resteront très
nombreux il aura donc fallu 28 ans pour
que le mur de la h soit frappé
d'inutilité reste maintenant à régler le
dossier allemand un dossier délicat qui
outre les Allemands concerne les alliés
de 45 essentiellement français
britannique américains et soviétique